nein
ich hatte mal einen Piercing also Tattoo
habe ich gar keins und Piercing hatte
ich mal eins im Bauchnabel das hat sich
entzündet und mein Bruder der Orthopäde
ist darf ich solange überhaupt Antworten
ja der ist gegen Verstümmelung des
Körpers also der ist gegen
einflusslöcher die nicht schon von Natur
ausgewachsen sind und dann warte ich
mein Bauchnabelpiercing extrem sehr
zündet und er hat es mir ein Ski Ferien
mit einem Messer entfernt es hat ganz
kurz sehr weh getan danach war es schön
man sieht auch nichts mehr davon ich
habe mir dann ja später noch mal eins
machen das hat sich wieder entzündet
erstaunlicherweise und jetzt habe ich
keine ich habe Ohrringe die Entzündung
manchmal habe ich so Knollen aber sonst
habe ich keine ein Löcher nein auch
keine Tattoos